in today's video I'm going to show you
how to add a no later than date to
action items in your Evernote hi Evan
Carmichael I believe when entrepreneurs
welcome to another technology Tuesday
video today i'm answering a question for
one of my YouTube subscribers love you
guys John who wrote in the SE kehna no
later then date for each of the action
items resulting from the meeting be
added to the calendar this is a great
question and the answer is kind of and
i'm going to hop over to my evernote
computer to show you how to do it so the
way to do this is to create a new note
and then add reminders so if i add a new
note and it could say make this video
super important there's a little alarm
clock at the top that you can then click
on and set a reminder for when this is
do so i can have a date and say i want
that to be in a week then you'll notice
that at the top of your notebooks here
it'll show you the reminder section and
when everything is due and if it's
something that I've accomplished and I
can check it off and I can it'll see
show here this check that could check it
again that it's not done yet and I see
the notification here if you're using
Evernote on the app you'll get you'll
get notifications within the app that
something is coming up and you can also
set it so that you get email reminders
and what happens is that email as you
the morning of to tell you that this
thing is do you can edit those settings
here and there tools go to options and
go to reminders and they'll say here
receive reminder emails emails to be
sent in the morning on days when notes
are due so that's a convenient part the
inconvenient part is as far as I know
you can only add reminders on new notes
so what would happen typically in a
meeting you may have a lot of things you
put within one note right you may have
you know to do's and you say John make
intro and Jill make you know marketing
slides and so on and you can't assign
individual reminders to all of these to
do is right you can only assign a
reminder to the note itself so you have
to do then is create a new note for
everything that you wanted to have a
different reminder for and then you can
set it up that way so a little bit
tricky a little bit confusing I know
typically when I do my
meetings I keep everything in one note
where what you have to do then is now
create individual notes for each to-do
item that you want to track so that's it
good luck thanks for the question Jon I
hope that helped you for those who are
watching if you liked the video and you
want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter continue to believe and if
you have any questions about Evernote or
other technology that i'm using feel
free to leave it in the comments below
and i just might make a video reply for
you